cardi b
celebrated her 28th birthday over the
weekend with her estranged tubby offset
and it looks like the two might not be
so estranged anymore
yeah the pair was spotted locking lips
at the birthday girls bash in las vegas
saturday night oh snappity-snap snap
yep cardi and offset standing at a club
k-i-s-s-i-n-g that's how it goes right
anyway they both documented the night on
social media
offset sharing this clip of cardi
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
yeah the migos rapper even reached out
and put his hand
on her booty before cardi started
dancing with him
then there was this
um from the looks of it this on-again
off-again couple
looks like they might be back on
[Music]
oh and that kiss came right after offset
gifted cardi with a rolls-royce
complete with their two-year-old
daughter's name embroidered on the seats
and that's not all the 28 year old also
surprised cardi with
a billboard in los angeles featuring a
pick of cardi and culture in matching
pink outfits
oh my goodness oh my god
i cardi shared
that video on instagram friday alongside
the caption quote
thank you sir i love it and on sunday
the [ __ ] rapper's actual birthday offset
posted a sweet tribute
to cardi writing in part quote you are
amazing woman you the best
me and culture are proud of you overcame
every obstacle in front of you
they was all asleep at once then you
woke the world up
he ended the b day message writing
simply i'm lucky
of course this all comes after cardi
filed for divorce from her hubby of
three years
in september i just got tired of
arguing i got tired of not seeing things
eye so before
when when you feel like it's just not
the same anymore
before you actually get cheated on i'd
rather just leave
at the time she hit up instagram live to
shut down the rumors that he had been
unfaithful
the reason why of my divorce is not
because none of that
that ever happened before it's not
because of cheating
no that's [ __ ] just a little
refresher
guardian offset tied the knot in
september 2017.
and the two welcomed their daughter
culture into the world in july 2018
but in december of that year cardi took
to instagram to reveal
she and the migos rapper were not
together anymore
one month later she told e.t this
working it out yeah taking it slow and
while the two had been
on and off for years they were seemingly
solid before cardi filed for divorce
you get tired sometimes and before
something bad happens before you get
left before you get cheated on
you sometimes you just want to leave
then last week
cardi addressed her relationship status
on instagram
writing quote single bad and rich i do
the controlling
and offset he double tapped that
so while it's unclear if these two are
back together
one thing's for sure they know how to
keep us guessing
you